có một cái mỗi kia của dùng đợt ngại ở quay nè tích tục lao thang.
Tổng thống Mỹ đưa năng tròm ngày mục bài tham bài tư mố,
Washington sẽ viện trở thêm bố khi chủ quay nè.
Theo ông Trump, một tiêu là giúp kia tự vệ,
trước khi đợt tâm công giữ giỏi tự vinh hà.
Trình đó có hạn loạt vụ không kích bằng ua vê và tên lừa.
Nhằm vào thủ đốt kia và nhiều thành phố lớn.
Tìm một này đưa đứa ra chỉ và ngày sau khu định đầm giữa tổng thống Trump
và tổng thống Uquay nè, bố lưu đi Miy Jelens K.
Cá hai nhất chi tăng cử hợp tác cuo phòng,
bao gồm khả năng của hợp sản xuất và mua sản thí bị quân sự
đặc biệt là trong lính vực phòng không.
Uquay nè đánh giá cao xấu chợt tự Mỹ trong việc năng càng năng lực phòng tụ bầu trời.
Giờ lúc mắt gà và nệ mạnh cái chính dịch không kích.
Tuy bài tổng thống Trump không đề cập đến việc cùng các hệ thống tên lửa patriót.
Rồi bố khi mạo Uquay nè nhiều lần khẩn tiếp têu gọi.
Trong bố cảnh mồn vệ trở từ Mỹ từ Mỹ, gián đoạn,
từ mố lần này phà năng nấu lực lâm só khăn kết của Washington, đối với K.
Trong dạm thêm cho Kục chiến.